nous étions dans les po nous attendait
et dans la téléréalité a ses réalités
le ciel qui se prend un râteau y en a
aussi beaucoup dans la réalité est là
vous allez voir une séquence
mon dieu mais le pauvre le pauvre
regardé et on commence notre top 5 des
râteaux avec steven de la villa des
coeurs brisés
dès les premières secondes il a compris
que c'était mort c'est une belle
personne je t'apprécie vraiment beaucoup
maintenant voilà je suis en train de
voir un prétendant quand je suis à que
quelques jours quand j'ai commencé à le
voir que tu m'apprécier moi je le savais
pas mais j'ai envie de te dire que je
suis très attaché à toi amicalement je
me suis pris un râteau laisse tomber le
mec et je me rends coach mais je me bats
bons numéros 4 il y a pire que de se
prendre un râteau il y à se prendre un
râteau devant ses potes et c'est ce qui
est arrivé à vincent shogun dans les
ch'tis versus les marseillais j'avais
jamais en membres c'est normal mais
j'ai vachement envie de lui faire un
bisou donc je lui faire un bisou on ne
veut pas
il se prend un vent monumental assez le
mistral en pleine tête la numéro 3
virgin dans les marseillais un jeune
homme qui a beaucoup de jugeote
il est ses copines à tenir sur des
talons il se fait passer pour le
meilleur ami gay et bim quand elle s'y
attend le moins il tente une action
déterminée attrayant par jour je sais
pas ce qui me prend mon sens il fait un
tour je me sent pousser des ailes
j'essaie de lui faire un petit bisou
donc visiblement elle a pas envie de
m'embrasser donc je pense que c'est ce
qu'on peut appeler un vent voire une
tornade
[Musique]
non pas du tout
direction les anges pour le numéro deux
un peu de justice dans ce monde de
brutes
après des centaines d'hommes lourds qui
se prennent des râteaux voici enfin la
berce un homme lourd mais qui met un
râteau moi je
[Musique]
c'est que ta mère tu sais que j'ai de
l'affection pour toi que c'est naturel
évident que m suspense jusqu'à cinq
tonnes
j'aime bien la relation qu'on a
guillaume
moi j'aimerais être la relation qu'on a
un beau duel reste comme neige
[Musique]
et enfin numéro un de notre top 5 des
râteaux mais l'analyse des anges à la
base dans les anges le but des candidats
est de trouver un projet professionnel
sauf que mélanie plutôt que de trouver
un taf elle voulait plutôt trouver
fabrice le parrain
ça fait neuf ans par les bons les autres
je suis flatté
de la numération sept ans pour moi mais
c'est
ça
deux choix de distance fois concentré
sur ce qu'on peut faire
si je suis bon sens avant mai 68
sincèrement non ce n'est pas une femme
en mariage
c'est juste le plus beau bâche de toutes
pièces
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand je viens
on peut pas avoir gueulé le succès très
clair un nez de mama mais quelque chose
oui ça m'arrive tout le temps d'ailleurs
j'ai fait des pieds râteau ça vient d'où
râteau c'est le contraire de l'appel ce
baiser langoureux mais aussi un
rapprochement politique de rater tout
simplement ravi de l'apprendre mais
comme une autre